we have some breaking news to bring you
and that is about Philip Schofield the
former presenter of itv's this morning
program because this evening he has quit
the broadcaster and that follows further
allegations about his private life he
has released a statement this evening
he's released it to the Daily Mail and
in it he admitted having a relationship
with a younger man while he was still
married and before he came out so let me
read that statement to you you're having
a look at it now I did have a consensual
on-off relationship with the younger
male colleague at this morning contrary
to speculation whilst I met the man when
he was a teenager and was asked to help
him to get into television it was only
after he started to work on the show
that it became more than just a
friendship that relationship was unwise
but not illegal it is now over Mr
Schofield goes on to say that in an
effort to protect my ex-colleague I
haven't been truthful about the
relationship but my recent unrelated
departure from this morning fueled
speculation and raised questions which
have been impacting him so for his sake
it is important for me to be honest
I am painfully conscious that I have
lied to my employers at ITV to my
colleagues and friends to my agents to
the media and therefore the public and
most importantly of all to my family I
am so very very sorry as I am for having
been unfaithful to my wife I have
therefore decided to step down from the
British soap Awards my last public
commitment and I am resigning from ITV
with immediate effect expressing my
immense gratitude to them for all the
amazing opportunities that they have
given me so that is the latest from
Philip Schofield this evening he said
that he is stepping down from hosting
the British soap awards that was meant
to be his last commitment and he said
he's resigning from ITV with immediate
effect and he's given the statement that
I was just reading to you admitted
having a relationship with a younger man
while he was still married and before he
came out he says he lied to his employer
his colleagues and his friends
but he described getting involved with
that younger man as unwise but not
illegal you remember he left this
morning last week and at the time he
said he would present the soap Awards
and that there was a new ITV show that
he'd be presenting no more he says he's
not doing the soap Awards and he's
quitting ITV